So let's define the global and
local hit rate.
The global hit rate can be defined as
simply 1 minus the global miss rate.
And the global miss rate can be defined
as the number of misses in this cache,
divided by the number of all memory
references that the processor makes,
not just those that reach this cache.
In contrast, the local hit rate and
the local miss rate can be defined in
terms of normal cache
behavior local to this cache.
So then local hit rate, for example,
is the number of hits divided by
the number of accesses to this cache.
And remember that not all
of the memory references
a processor makes actually
reach this cache.
The local miss rate simply can be the
number of misses divided by the number
of accesses and they,
of course, still add up to 1.
Another popular metric of how
often the cache hits that tries
to capture the behavior of caches that
are not the level 1 cache, is misses
per 1000 instructions, or MPKI,
where K stands for kilo instructions.
It is very similar to the global
miss rate, except that
it doesn't normalize the misses with
the number of just memory accesses.
It normalizes with
the number of instructions.